Your job is now is to implement the backward Euler method for the SEIR model.
We provide the forward Euler method as a starting point.
So this end, we have reshuffled the order--EISR to make things easier.
We can start with the R equation using what you have computed for E and I and S before
and then you can continue with S and with I.
Doing the backward Euler method for E, it's a little harder.
We provided the solution in case you don't want to spend that time.
If you start from the bottom, you can check your result whether or not it make sense
by running the software for that single line.
When you're done, set the time step to 5 days to see that
this method can handle such a long time step.